as far as the quarterback position you
know like like every other position
there'll be competition there um but you
know in that position you know we're
looking for leadership we're looking for
obviously accuracy we're looking for
um you know someone who you you know for
the most part can lead the team
brian flores the head coach of miami
dolphins talking about what he's looking
for to quarterback every team's looking
forward to starting quarterback the
challenge though is do you go with the
veteran that you brought in ryan
fitzpatrick or do you entrust the job to
the guy you traded four during round two
of the draft josh rosen three years 6.2
million dollars a great opportunity to
test him out see what you have before
deciding what you do with a draft pick
in 2020 and we had believed that this
was just going to be rosen's gig yeah
flora has made it clear that there will
be an open competition right fitzpatrick
is the best guy he'll play and yeah you
know i look i look at it this way if
josh rosen can't beat out ryan
fitzpatrick then then maybe you have
your answer to whether or not he's a guy
long term i think that pretty much says
it all you're right i mean it's
certainly going to throw caution in the
wind to anybody out there if if we come
out and it's the start of september and
ryan fitzpatrick's starting quarterback
and there's no injury involved with josh
rosen i do believe it'll be open
competition because that's what brian
flores is trying to create there in
miami with a new organization that
nobody just gets handed a spot no matter
who you are or what we think you might
be
but i would be absolutely shocked if
josh rosen is in the corner we know what
ryan fitzpatrick is at this point of his
career we know that and we know if
you're a miami dolphins you know front
office guy or whatever it may be that
yeah he can add some value to your team
but he's not the long-term answer josh
rosen is the guy they are going to favor
certainly and he's going to have to
screw it up to not be a starter yeah
they traded a second round pick he has a
chance to become the franchise down
there and become that guy for a long
long time which will allow them to use
next year's assets to build the rest of
their football team that's where it was
a great move and i i'm with you it's
it'd be it's trouble for josh rosen if
he couldn't beat a ryan fitzpatrick i
fully expect him to be able to pick up
the offense and he's physically more
gifted than ryan fitzpatrick as well so
uh really think it's a kind of a win-win
situation for him as long as he just
handles his business yeah and there's a
tension
within the dolphins organization
about this whole concept of tanking now
no one's ever going to call it that i'm
sure but chris greer the gm brian flores
a head coach and that part of it is you
have to say it but they seem to be
offended by the suggestion that this is
a team that would take a step back take
their lumps because the only way you're
going to get that new franchise
quarterback is to end up high enough in
the draft where you can grab them
otherwise you just got to get lucky that
a guy slips through like like they did
in 1983 when dan mourinho slipped all
the way down to the bottom of the round
sure i think ownership i think the
attitude is you know what
it's okay to take a disastrous year yeah
if it gets you the guy you want right
and i'd love to know
what went on in the organization when
stephen ross signed off
on the trade for josh rosen does he
believe this is the guy that's going to
turn it around for them they don't have
to take their lumps they can go all in
with rosen yeah or do they maybe still
take their lumps and reserve the right
to go after you know justin herbert or
or tuatango by lower next year yeah well
i think they're just going to see how it
plays out i think at the very least they
see the potential in rosen to go this
could be the guy you know again he it's
a system fit and he has talent you know
rosen uh yeah we worried about you know
his lack of size or maybe ability to
take a beating in the nfl okay that's
still maybe a concern but everything
else is pretty damn good for this guy i
mean he's a very good thrower the
football he's a good decision maker this
is the new england offense they're
running down there so from that
standpoint i thought i think it should
make sense and they're not tanking but
they're not exactly yes you know brian
flores isn't going to tank he's going to
make his guys compete but you're right
the organization's not setting itself up
to be at its absolute best for 2019
they're looking for the future to be at
their absolute best yeah it's always a
tough balance you want to win as many
games as you can but you're also trying
to build something year and year out
they added a running back over the
weekend mark walton again was arrested
three times in the off-season cut by the
cincinnati bengals yeah they brought him
in on a tryout basis ended up giving him
a spot on the 90-man roster brian flores
said i think people deserve a second
chance i believe that i think that's the
case i don't want to judge people based
on one incident two incidents actually
three incidents i think that it's a
case-by-case situation for a player and
for people in general that's kind of my
stance look we've been down this road
before
you have to be talented to get the
second chance right the guys who aren't
talented don't get the second chance and
remember folks
anyone who gets a second chance on a
53-man roster in a 32-team league it
takes away someone else's first chance
that's that's the thing i never want to
lose sight of somebody's dream is ending
because somebody who got himself into
some trouble and is earning a second
chance or getting a second chance
somebody else's first chance is going to
go away i think we think of it that way
maybe we're a little more reticent to
just welcome a guy back because he's
talented yeah i mean maybe there's two
things that jump out to me here first of
all brian flores is a stand-up man he's
not just going to sign some idiot off
the street this kid went to the
university of miami i'm sure the miami
dolphins have a lot of inside info on
who the kid is third you know out of the
things you can get arrested for you know
misdemeanor marijuana okay
carrying a concealed weapon and then a
slight difference between the two well
i'm just saying either one of them they
might not be the most egregious worst
things we've ever seen in the world
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports